I do feel like you're like on this sort
of like how long have you have you been
making videos for since 2016. does it
feel like now you're like getting a
crazy amount of attention all of a
sudden
um yeah I I think it kind of ramped up
in the past couple of years for sure
yeah yeah like after you went on Joe
Rogan for the first time did they have
like a noticeable effect on it was the
only podcast I've been on that I saw
like a blatant blip it wasn't it's not
like uh some people talk about it as if
it's gonna make or break your not break
but make your career this one will break
yeah you'll notice yeah you'll see that
noticeable blip in the opposite yeah
it like I don't know for example if
you're going up like one or two thousand
Subs a day all of a sudden it's like 10
for a couple days and then it kind of
just Peters back out but yeah you see a
noticeable change for sure yeah dude I
obviously the liver King thing happened
I'm like God damn I can't wait for this
but I have to say for your Channel I
feel like some of the breakdowns you do
weirdly I think you cover off on I don't
know things that like are obvious in
some ways but to some people are not
like whenever you break down like
celebrities doing roids I still think
that's something that a lot of people
don't realize one of my wife's like good
friends she couldn't believe that The
Rock was potentially juicing yeah and we
had this big kind of it was it was like
a tongue-in-cheek argument but it was
like this explosive thing where I'm like
you need to watch [ __ ] more place
more dates like the dude is not natural
and she's like nah I don't think so and
then it was like her my wife and then
all her friends being like Chris Evans
is natural like no he's not and yeah I
thought I mean I fall for it yeah and I
thought the rock before I started
watching you and started doing more
research on steroids and getting more
into like The Natty or not kind of
community or whatever I really thought
like all these guys were that was just
like genetically gifted and like that's
why they're famous yeah I was like the
rock is just a beast like that yeah yeah
some of them are natural though let's
not like take away no no no no no no no
but but some of them yeah blatantly
lying or just avoiding it entirely but
yeah even in like the immediate circle
of people who are in the know like I've
seen podcasts with Joe or even his
friends Tony Hinchcliffe he was like you
think the Rock's on steroids yeah and
Rogan's like yeah no [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
he's like no yeah no way yeah it's
definitely I think he is right yeah yeah
he's one of my favorite celebs yeah dude
I think there's a part of that with the
rock like everybody loves them so they
just don't want to believe that's what
I'm saying but I don't think it would
really do you think it would like
tarnish his brand at all probably yeah
yeah because people think steroids are
like bad for some reason yeah it's like
the antithesis of Health and Longevity
because it's very much just I am
sustaining an unhealthy amount of mass
to play roles to get you to like yeah
more essentially yeah but but is there
like a healthy dose where you could you
know put on some muscle and not shorten
your life yeah it's kind of uh there's a
the further you push it the worse it's
going to be of course and you know for
some people who have good tolerability
of drugs you could potentially get away
with a decent amount but it kind of
depends some people die in their 20s and
they abuse the [ __ ] out of it some
people smoke incessantly forever and
live the you know 90. yeah it kind of
depends there's no real way to test for
like your body's appetite for Roy's is
there or well yeah you could check your
blood work see how [ __ ] up it is at
Baseline and then you take you know gear
and then see what happens to it or get
uh ultrasounds of your organs or
whatever most people aren't going to do
that though and then one day they have a
Jammer and they didn't know the entire
time they probably shouldn't have taken
it to begin with
what's a Jammer like a heart attack oh
okay okay that's just slang for a heart
attack yeah that's like industry phrase
I've heard yeah I'm sorry I'm late I
[ __ ] got another Jammer
it's pretty Canadian word I've ever
heard for a heart attack dude how's pop
say oh I had a big Jammer this weekend
yeah
[ __ ] her at another Jammer hey oh the
belt boys
I just did like five lines got a [ __ ]
Jammer in the bathroom
my chest [ __ ] hurts bud
I'm Natty for sure yeah Nettie our boy's
natty man come on and you can tell it's
Natty because he's 50 and he's twice the
size he was 25 years ago
well that's what happens as you get
older you get bigger too yeah like holy
[ __ ] look at that oh dude the left gives
me hope yeah but the left is like it
could be me I just need like five inches
of height and you know 80 pounds of Mass
dude oh I'm gonna your line needs to
move back like three inches I know dude
I need to eat ice cream now yeah all
right you shouldn't yeah you should have
saved all that good advice you gave me
you should have just sent this and then
like what do you want to be you know
right to the left anyway sorry you were
saying something Derek I cut you up
um no it was just uh the the thing about
the before too is I'm sure he was
working his ass off too yeah so it's
like the the delusion that goes into oh
yeah now he's just natural for sure but
yeah you know why would he lie to us
yeah
yeah it is a it because I wasn't really
you know I don't know [ __ ] about
bodybuilding or like working out at all
and I think about just I would go to the
gym like in late high school early
college I see these dudes that are
[ __ ] massive and I just think damn
I just gotta be in here enough and you
know eventually
and now when I think back
when I signed up for my membership you
know like every gym they make you sign
that thing like and you promise you're
not gonna sell roids in here
that's a thing in your gym contract I
thought this was normal though this is
even funnier I feel like I feel like
Gold's in Venice it's like you have to
agree that you will buy or sell right
there okay that's all right all right
that's different then but no at the gym
in my town they made you sign like a
thing that was like I won't sell like
foreign substances on the premise and I
I asked the dude uh like at this moment
only clicked with me years later where I
was like oh yeah dude guy like me is
gonna be selling roids and the the guy
who signed me up he was like Hey man be
surprised there's a lot of dudes like
you and I just it kind of escaped me but
as it just I don't know then I realized
like this dude's like you me like I
think he meant like just like small guys
being in there being like Oh like you
want some [ __ ] and that image is
recently just been in my mind of like
this guy that's small as [ __ ] and he's
juicing up all the guys in the gym that
are like [ __ ] massive and they're
like like who's your [ __ ] roid's plug
it's like I have that 80 pound [ __ ]
vaguely Asian guy over there
anyway no real point to that but
yeah
so dude what what do we need what do we
need to be like that
if you were to give us just like a
generic list something that doesn't cost
twelve thousand dollars a month you're
talking about the left or the right the
right
new genetics new genetics [ __ ] all right
let's kill ourselves let's come back
dude respond yeah we gotta respawn yeah
damn it are you on anything right now I
just take trt now okay quarter but
downsize then when I was Full Tilt so
you're not like lifting as much anymore
no even just just remote entrepreneurial
perspective for me just how much mental
resources do I want to allocate to
lifting heavy [ __ ] all the time yeah not
that I don't lift but it's like it's not
as intensive as it used to be I don't
eat copious amounts like I used to I try
to be more mindful of like a hybrid
between work productivity and kind of
like sustaining just like a healthier
more sustainable lifestyle that's great
dude so you're like the real Rock
hey
I wouldn't say that I think you're
saying that I think you're saying that
we're putting words that was totally
what I implied yeah yeah yeah yeah no
we're putting words in your mouth dude
this is a this is a [ __ ] drama
podcast dude yeah let's stir some [ __ ]
up